Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Forschergeist, dem Podcast des Stifterverbands für die deutsche Wissenschaft. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und das hier ist die 17. Ausgabe unserer Gesprächsserie hier über Wissenschaft, über wissenschaftliche Methoden, über die Organisation der Wissenschaft und auch immer wieder der versuch, einen blick nach außen zu wagen. Und heute blicken wir wirklich mal ein wenig über den deutschen Tellerrand hinaus. Ich bin ein weiteres Mal unterwegs in England. Wieder in Cambridge, aber diesmal an einem ganz anderen Ort, als das letzte mal. Nämlich beim Sankt Johns College bin ich gelandet hier in der Cambridge University und spreche mit Ulinka Rublak. Schönen guten Tag.
Guten Tag.
Sie sind ja hier Professorin für frühneuzeitliche Geschichte Europas? Das ist richtig?
Das ist richtig. Also frühe Neuzeit heißt vor allem Geschichte des 16. und 17. Jahrhunderts. Reformationsgeschichte zum Beispiel.
Die frühe Neuzeit. Und wann endet die frühe Neuzeit? Also wann ist die Neuzeit nicht mehr so neu?
Mit der französischen Revolution im allgemeinen. Also sonst um 1750, solche Epochengrenzen sind natürlich immer sehr willkürlich gesetzt. Aber im Grunde genommen kann man sagen, 1450-1750.
Das ist ja eigentlich ein sehr eingeschränkter Zeitraum oder?
Finden Sie?
Ja. Also es ist sicherlich einiges passiert, aber es könnte ja jetzt auch Jahr Millionen zurückblicken.
Ja also es ist natürlich so, man wird ja für bestimmte Epochengrenzen angestellt. Und dann gibt es eben Altertum, aber bei meiner Fakultät fängt es an mit mittelalter und dann gibt es eben die frühe Neuzeit und dann kommt die Neuzeit. Und das ist in Deutschland im Allgemeinen auch so, aber das Altertum kommt eben in Deutschland mit rein bei den historischen Fakultäten. Und man denkt natürlich über diese Epochengrenzen selber hinaus. Und liest sehr viel weiter. Aber wenn ich lehre mache, dann bin ich eben für diese Jahrhunderte gefragt.
Okay. Wir wollen heute mal ja sowohl, also mich interessiert sowohl Geschichte eigentlich als Forschungsfeld. Das ist ja, wenn ich das mal so unterstellen darf, gemeinhin nicht unbedingt immer das erste, was einem einfällt, wenn man über Forschung nachdenkt. Also traditionell denkt man bei Forschung immer über das Neue, die Zukunft, das Ungesehene, und Geschichte dreht das ja in gewisser Hinsicht um und man blickt explizit auf etwas, was halt schon mal da war. Ich weiß nicht, ob Ihnen das auch so begegnet oder ist das jetzt nur meine Sicht der dinge?
Es ist sicherlich eine Sicht der dinge, die viele Menschen teilen. Bei mir war es sicherlich anders. Also ich habe schon immer die Welt als historisch verfasst erlebt. Und mir war immer klar, dass ich die Gegenwart und die Zukunft nur verstehe, wenn ich auch die Geschichte verstehe. Dass sich das gar nicht so trennen lässt. Und mir selber fällt es extrem schwer, geschichtslos zu denken. Das ist mir persönlich unmöglich eigentlich. Aber ich weiß, dass es diese Haltung gibt.
Dass es sogar den meisten so geht oder?
Vielleicht ist das so. also ich höre es immer wieder, dass das so der Fall ist. Vor allen dingen in Amerika, da habe ich jetzt gerade wieder ein Gespräch gehabt, dass es Studenten ganz unmöglich ist, sich vorzustellen, dass es eine Welt gab, in der 80% der Bevölkerung auf dem Land lebten und Eliterat waren, wie sagt man, also eben nicht lesen und nicht schreiben konnten. Also Analphabeten waren und Bauern. Dass sie sich das schlichtweg nicht vorstellen können. Aber mich hat natürlich schon als Kind gerade das fasziniert. Also was historisch war, was anders war. Gerade um immer wieder auszuloten, inwiefern waren diese Gesellschaften eben anders, aber auch was verbindet sie denn mit unserer eigenen? Und da muss man natürlich sagen, dass Ängste auch immer wieder verbinden. Dass Hoffnungen verbinden.
Dass bestimmte, also Sie haben die Naturwissenschaften angesprochen, mit dieser Vorstellung, dass sie eben immer das Neue sind und das Zukünftige und dann schaut man sich im Buch, was ich gerade abgeschlossen habe, über Johannes Keppler, den deutschen Astronom, dann schaut man sich eben so eine Figur des frühen 17. Jahrhunderts an. Also der Scientific Revolution und dann merkt man, dass genau das natürlich da schon die tragende Idee ist. Dass das das Zukünftige bringt. Und gleichzeitig ist er dann natürlich aus der heutigen Warte jemand, der uns extrem fremd vorkommt. Glauben an die Astrologie, hat Horoskope gesammelt und so weiter und so fort. Hat daran geglaubt, dass die erde belebt ist und so relativiert sich auch viel von den Claims, also den Ansprüchen, die heute gemacht werden.
Also auch die Zukunft ändert sich sozusagen mit der Zeit?
Das ist genau richtig.
Was war denn so der  ich meine, gab es so was, ich unterstelle das jetzt einfach mal  gab es so etwas, so einen Moment in Ihrem Leben, wo Ihnen so klar geworden ist, dass Geschichte so eine Bedeutung hat? Also dass sich die Gegenwart und die Zukunft nicht deuten lässt, ohne Geschichte? Also gibt es da irgend so einen besonderen Moment? Manchmal hat man so was ja.
In meinem Fall ist das sicherlich ein bisschen anders. Weil mein Vater war Historiker an der Universität Tübingen und in dem sinne bin ich mit Geschichte aufgewachsen und wie gesagt habe eben schon als Kind, weil ich war dann immer fasziniert, ein Buch zu lesen, über einen Etrusker sagen wir oder über das alte Rom. Also das war einfach teil meines Lebens, dass ich so gelesen und gedacht habe.
Okay, aber trotzdem muss ja, ist ja nicht so, dass jetzt alle Kinder gleich nach ihren Eltern kommen?
Nein, also ich meine natürlich habe ich verschiedene Karrierewege angedacht und als ich Geschichte dann ausgewählt habe und studiert habe, da wusste ich, also dass ich eigentlich überhaupt nicht in die Richtung will, die mein Vater gewählt hatte. Also ich wollte, mich hat vor allem Technikgeschichte interessiert und eher das 19. Jahrhundert. Und das hat sich dann aber relativ schnell geändert, und zwar, und das sagt auch viel darüber aus, warum ich dann nach England gegangen bin, und zwar war es die Zeit in den späten 80er und 90er Jahren, als eine ganz neue Richtung in der Geschichte aufkam. Das nannte sich methodisch-historische Anthropologie und es ging eben vor allem um die Wahrnehmungsweisen und die Möglichkeiten, Handlungsmöglichkeiten von allen Gruppen in er Geschichte.
Also eben weg von der Geschichte der Eliten, hin zu der Frage nach der Geschichte der Bauern, der Frauen und so weiter.
Methodisch historische Anthropologie?
Ja historische Anthropologie.
Also dass man mehr die Rollen der Personen hinterfragt?
Genau. Also es ging eben um eine methodische Mischung von der Geschichte mit anthropologischen Vorgehensweisen. Also dass man sich sozusagen wie ein Anthropologe im sagen wir 16./17. Jahrhunderte bewegte und da ganz anders fragt. Zum Beispiel nach Ritualen, nach der Bedeutung von Symbolen für diese Gesellschaften. Und wie gesagt eben nach den Handlungsmöglichkeiten von Menschen in Gemeinschaften und wegging von der damals noch sehr traditionellen Diplomatie und Politikgeschichte.
Könige.
Genau und inzwischen hat sich die natürlich auch ganz stark geändert, diese Diplomatie- und Politikgeschichte. Also die hat sich gerade ihren eigenen Ritual turn gemacht. Vor allem in Deutschland, gibt es sehr interessante Forschungen, also auch da war natürlich genau das ebenso, war natürlich Rituale genau das, was Weltordnung, symbolische Weltordnung konstituiert hat. Aber wir haben eben vor allem angefangen mit einem Interesse an den gewöhnlichen Leuten. Weil mir klar wurde, auch in der Schule, was habe ich in der Schule eigentlich gelernt über ganz gewöhnliche Leute? Und die Annahme war eben, dass die nicht nur eine Masse waren, nicht nur Leute waren, denen alles diktiert wurde, was sie zu denken hatten, sondern dass sie tatsächlich ihre eigenen Denk- und Aneignungsweisen hatten. Und dass sie deshalb hochinteressante Subjekte der Geschichte sind.
Also ein Verständnis der Kultur und daraus ergibt sich die Geschichte? Ist denn diese Methodik, um das nochmal aufzugreifen, wo kam das her? Also wo hat sich das entwickelt, Geschichte so neu anzugehen, neu zu interpretieren?
Also das hat sich, da gab es einige Vertreter in den Staaten, aber hier in Cambridge war vor allem jemand namens Peter Burke sehr interessant, Kulturwissenschaftler hier in der Universität. Dann mein Doktorvater Robert Scribner war sehr wegweisend. Das waren alles Einsätze, die wurden in Deutschland vor allem bekämpft von vielen Historikern an der Universität. Das wurde also sehr problematisch wahrgenommen. Beziehungsweise wurde immer diese Vorstellung, dass die Menschen ihren Eigensinn hatten, die Subjekte ihren Eigensinn hatten, das wurde zugunsten einer Strukturgeschichte, die vor allem von Wehler und anderen sehr prominenten Historikern vertreten wurde, wurde das sehr marginalisiert. Und hier fand ich eine große Offenheit eben für ganz verschiedene Ansätze, wo eben diese historische Anthropologie sich auch entwickeln konnte und das hat mich sehr angezogen.
Wann haben Sie angefangen zu studieren? Also wann war die Entscheidung für Geschichte dann durch?
Das war glaube ich im 87.
Das war in Deutschland ja. Also ich habe ganz normal angefangen. Also ich habe in Hamburg Abitur gemacht und habe dann da angefangen, zu studieren. Auch Kunstgeschichte, für mich ist visuelle Geschichte dann auch sehr wichtig geworden. Da gab es wunderbare Professoren zu der Zeit. Und Soziologie. Und dann war es natürlich so, dass es in Hamburg zu der Zeit wirklich eine Massenuni war. Also die Seminare waren überfüllt, es war noch sehr schwierig, zu kommunizieren untereinander und sinnvoll Unterricht zu gestalten und dann wurde ich sehr früh ab dem 3. Semester gefördert vom evangelischen Studienwerk Villigst und hatte ein Stipendium, mit dem klar war, ich könnte eben studieren, wo ich wollte. Und da habe ich überlegt, was will ich eigentlich am meisten. Ich überlegte Paris, in dieser Zeit waren Foucault und waren andere Denker, die mich auch sehr inspirierten. Aber ich dachte in Cambridge gibt es eben Figuren wie Peter Burke, Bob Scribner, aber es gibt vor allem auch eine ganz andere Art der lehre.
Aber in Deutschland?
Es gibt ganz kleine Seminare und habe mich dann entschlossen, ich will vor allem wirklich, i want to be tought. Ich möchte unterrichtet werden auf eine Art und Weise, die eben in Deutschland unmöglich war. Und deshalb bin ich dann her gekommen für ein Jahr als Studentin.
Was hat das so unmöglich gemacht? War das jetzt nur die Tatsache, dass der Studiengang überlaufen war?
Also er war tatsächlich überlaufen. Viele Leute haben im Nebenfach studiert und hatten eben begrenztes Interesse. Das war ja so, dass die Seminare damals eben so abliefen, dass da vor allem Referate gehalten wurden. Die Referate waren eben oft von fragwürdiger Qualität und dann hat der Professor dann am Schluss nochmal zusammengefasst in den letzten 10 Minuten, was die wichtigen Perspektiven eigentlich waren. Dann hat man sich da so ein bisschen festgeklammert. Aber es hat eigentlich für keinen so richtig Sinn gemacht oft.
Man wurde zusammengefasst?
Also jetzt vor allem in der Geschichte muss man sagen. Man wurde zusammengefasst. Aber es war eben, die Motivationen waren einfach sehr unterschiedlich. Wie gesagt, in der Kunstgeschichte habe ich oft sinnvollere Impulse, auch in der Soziologie., also ich will das auch nicht alles über einen Kamm scheren, und auch niemanden kritisieren. Aber ich würde es so zusammenfassen, dass dort die Motivationslagen sehr sehr unterschiedlich waren.
Die Motivationslagen der Professoren oder?
Ja sowohl der Professoren als auch der Studenten. Und dann natürlich ist das deutsche System war damals so, dass einem relativ wenig Hilfe gegeben wurde. Also man musste sich die Bibliografie vor allem selber zusammenstellen für diese Referate. Und man wurde eben angeleitet dazu, wissenschaftlich eigenständig zu arbeiten. Was eine ganz tolle Sache war eigentlich. Aber natürlich in der Praxis viele Leute überfordert hat.
Warum?
Naja weil das eben, sagen wir mal, man muss dann natürlich auf die Literatur kommen, die einen wirklich weiterführt. Das ist oft gar nicht so. also es braucht einfach Zeit. Und wie soll man das denn wissen, wenn man im ersten Semester ist oder selbst noch im dritten und zum ersten Mal mit einem Thema konfrontiert wird. Und dann natürlich auch praktisch. Also in Hamburg war die Bibliothek nicht besonders gut ausgestattet. Da musste man Fernleihen machen und dann dauerte das erst mal ein paar Wochen, bis das Buch da war und dann war das Referat auch schon wieder vorbei und so weiter und so fort. Und eben die Professoren, wie sollten sie auch so viele Anleitungen geben, wenn es eben so viele Studenten gab. Und das ist hier natürlich ganz anders. Also hier sagen wir den Studenten von Woche zu Woche genau, welches Kapitel sie in welchem Buch zu lesen haben und welchen Artikel sie zu lesen haben. Und damit können die dann sehr schnell sehr große Themenzusammenhänge effektiv bearbeiten. Das ist dann verschulter und kanonisierter, aber es ist andererseits dann auch im Gespräch, was man mit denen hat, zumindest so, dass dann Wissen entsteht, auf dessen Basis man dann individuell weiter zusammen nachdenken kann. Und auch erst mal diese Grundlage vermittelt bekommt.
Haben Sie das denn gleich als offensichtliches Hindernis verstanden in dem Moment? Also war das sozusagen sofort klar, hier ist es zu voll und dieses Referatsystem funktioniert nicht oder ist das etwas, was einem erst später klar wird, wenn man das mit anderen Erfahrungen paart?
Naja doch...
Am Anfang denkt man ja vielleicht erst mal, es liegt an einem selbst. Es liegt ja vielleicht auch an einem selbst manchmal.
Ja also natürlich habe ich mich auch erst mal einfinden müssen. In den ersten zwei Semestern. Und ich wusste auch nicht, wie man ein Referat schreibt und dass da Fußnoten rein gehören usw. und so fort. Mein erstes Referat habe ich auch zurück gekriegt, weil ich gedacht hatte, das ist nicht so wichtig, dass da Fußnoten drin sind und so weiter. Aber dann war es natürlich zunehmend so, dass ich immer wieder merkte, da sind eben auch grenzen dieses Systems, eben dann dass man so viel Zeit in Arbeitsgruppen verbrachte. Und die fanden dann vor allem über frühstücke statt, die man zusammen einnahm. Also das war wirklich eine Universitätskultur, die sich glaube ich auch inzwischen wirklich geändert hat. Und das war dann eigentlich schon im dritten Semester, deshalb wollte ich dann eben auch weggehen. Andererseits hatte ich eben vor allem, ich glaube es kam auch tatsächlich durch meine Förderung des Studienwerk Villigst, weil wir da eben dann auch Seminare hatten.
Und ich merkte, das ist eine ganz andere Intensität, also da haben wir dann wirklich intensiv Lesegruppen gehabt, wo wir auf einem völlig anderen Niveau reden konnten über schwierige texte. Also Levinas, das war wirklich damals die Zeit der Postmoderne, wo man sich intensiv mit Theoretikern auch sehr interdisziplinär auseinandergesetzt hat. Und all das konnte ich da tun, aber ich konnte es eben nicht an der Universität umsetzen.
Machte sich denn der Unmut auch so bei anderen Studenten breit oder hatten Sie das Gefühl, da die einzige zu sein?
Nein, das war sicherlich allgemein. Aber da wir ich natürlich nicht die einzige. Und was heißt Unmut? Also es war halt einfach, wie ich gesagt habe, also bestimmte Professoren in der Soziologie. und in der Kunstgeschichte vor allem waren auch extrem inspirierend. Also in der Kunstgeschichte habe ich Leute wie Martin Warnke und Horst Bredekamp gehört und die haben mir unheimlich viel gegeben. Und Monika Wagner auch. Also es war ja überhaupt nicht alles schlecht. Aber sozusagen die Umstände drumherum, die machten es einfach für alle sehr sehr schwierig, produktiv zu arbeiten.
Wenn wir von vielen Studenten in einem Studiengang sprechen, welche Zahl muss man sich da jetzt vorstellen? Was ist viel, was ist zu viel?
Also die Zahlen für die Studiengänge habe ich nicht mehr im Kopf, aber ich denke mir einfach, so ein typisches Seminar da waren einfach 40-50 Leute drin. Und es war ja eben ganz stark auf Mitarbeit orientiert und auf die Diskussionen. Wie gesagt, diese Referate, und das war dann, als ich hier war einfach unglaublich. Dann habe tatsächlich sozusagen einen internationalen Star, wie Peter Burke gehört, der eine Vorlesung gemacht hat über die Annales-Schule und da saßen eben 12 Leute drin oder ich habe einen anderen Kurs bei ihm gemacht, der eben auch sehr interaktiv war, da waren wir 7 Leute. Und das ist eben eine Elitenuniversität hier. Das ist dann auch, ich will das sozusagen mein Argument für die deutsche Universität ist auch nach wie vor, dass es absolut richtig ist, dass die deutsche Universität keine Elitenuniversität ist, so wie Cambridge hier.
Aber dass sie nach wie vor so viel wie möglich in genug Lehrpersonal investieren muss und gut ausgestattete Bibliotheken.
Also mit anderen Worten, es ist kein Fehler, sich auf die breite auszurichten, aber man sollte es halt auch nur dann tun oder zumindest auf eine Art und Weise tun, die dann den entsprechenden Zahlen, die dort anwachsen, auch gerecht wird.
Genau. Und ich glaube, das bleibt nach wie vor die große Utopie für die deutsche Bildungslandschaft. Also nicht ein Elitensystem zu schaffen, wie hier, sondern weiter wirklich zu bestätigen, was da geschaffen worden ist und das ist was wunderbares. Ich sehe hier natürlich auch die ganze Zeit die Grenzen und Probleme des Elitensystems. Also wie man das für Amerika auch sagen kann mit den Ivy League Universities. Und ich denke mir immer für Deutschland, Deutschland will nicht Universitäten schaffen wie Harvard, aber es sollte sich zu dem bekennen, was so gut ist an dem deutschen System und es noch besser machen.
Also Sie haben das Studium dann erst mal in England fortgesetzt?
Also ich war hier nur für ein Jahr.
Auch in Cambridge?
Dann wollte ich auch - ja in Cambridge - dann wollte ich aber dezidiert nach Deutschland zurück, weil hier studiert man eben nur ein Fach, hier studiert man eben nur Geschichte. Und ich Deutschland finde ich das eben auch fantastisch, ich habe da drei Fächer studiert, Kunstgeschichte, Soziologie und Geschichte und Sozialwirtschaftsgeschichte und da wollte ich eben auch den Abschluss machen und ich wollte auch ein MA machen, wo man also eben einen Magister, wo man dann eine längere Forschungsarbeit schreibt, das ist hier auch nicht der Fall. Also man wird tatsächlich, wenn man das sozusagen das selber schafft, dann wurde man damals in Deutschland fantastisch für eine wissenschaftliche Laufbahn ausgebildet. Hier ist es nach wie vor oft für Doktoranden ein großes Problem, dass sie natürlich nie das kennengelernt haben, dass sie sich ihre eigene Literatur zusammen suchen. Und all das habe ich in Deutschland natürlich perfekt gelernt.
Also war dann auch gar nicht so von Nachteil die Anforderungen sozusagen?
Nein für mich war es das nicht. Wenn man das sozusagen also wenn man das System auszufüllen weiß, dann hat es, und wenn man dann eine wissenschaftliche Laufbahn wollte, dann hatte es große Vorteile.
Jetzt paar interessante Sachen, die das quasi mit aufbringt. Einerseits dieser begriff Elitenuniversität, ist das etwas, was inwiefern, vielleicht können Sie das auch mal ein bisschen beschreiben, was ist da sozusagen die Realität hier in  reden wir von England oder reden wir von Großbritannien?
Wir reden von Oxford und Cambridge.
Wir reden von Oxford und Cambridge spezifisch. Was hat das für eine konkrete Ausprägung? Wer kommt hierher und warum?
Also und was ist das Problem? Also das geht ja sehr tief in England. Also da muss man eben bei den Schulsystemen anfangen. Man muss anfangen mit dem großen Traum für schon viele Mittelschichtsfamilien, dass ihr Kind es schafft, in Cambridge oder Oxford aufgenommen zu werden. Und das gilt nach wie vor eben als das beste oft und ist natürlich eben ganz konkret mit sehr guten Berufschancen und einfach höherem Einkommen dann verbunden. Das heißt es geht letztendlich natürlich um den Traum von der entweder Reproduktion oder Produktion von sozialen Privilegien. Und diesen Traum haben eben dann viele, weil sie denken, das ist dann das beste für ihr Kind und deshalb wird schon in die Schulkarrieren entsprechend investiert. Es gibt ja hier sehr viele Privatschulen und nach wie vor ist es so, dass dann durch die kleineren Klassen und den besseren Unterricht mehr Leute von Privatschulen dann auch nach Oxford und Cambridge kommen.
Das heißt mit Kosten von ungefähr 20.000 Pfund im Jahr ist dann entsprechend investiert. Wir versuchen natürlich, in Cambridge und Oxford so gut wir es können das auch umzudrehen und es wird ganz viel mit staatlichen schulen kooperiert, aber es ist so, dass viele Schüler in staatlichen schulen einfach denken Oxford und Cambridge ist nicht für sie da, ist nicht für sie gemacht, dass sie da gar nicht hingehören und das ist das was so schrecklich ist. Und wir versuchen das zu ändern, aber es ist immer noch so, dass so um die Hälfte oder sogar ein bisschen drüber der Leute, die wir auswählen, kommen eben aus den Privatschulen.
Wie groß ist denn so die gefühlte Distanz zwischen Oxford, Cambridge und den anderen Universitäten?
Ja das es gibt natürlich noch ein paar weitere, die auch sehr gut sind, aber trotzdem würde ich sagen, sie ist sehr weit. Und dann gibt es natürlich noch innerhalb von England noch dieses Gefälle zwischen dem Süden und dem norden. Also die Leute aus dem norden kommen noch viel weniger hierher, fühlen sich noch viel weniger dazugehörig. Und auch da versuchen wir sehr stark, daran zu arbeiten, dass die sich hier überhaupt bewerben. Und dann heißt Elite natürlich ganz handfest, dass man sich hier eben überhaupt nur bewerben kann, wenn man für die A-Labels, was dem Abitur entspricht, also ein A-Star und zwei As hat, also ein ganz super Abi vorzuweisen hat, sonst kann man sich hier nicht bewerben. Und dann werden also die Leute, die bewerben sich am College und da werden sie dann meistens interviewt und dann wird eben persönlich ausgewählt.
Das hießt sie müssen dann einfach nochmal eine reihe von Tests und Gesprächen durchlaufen und danach wird dann eben gesagt, ob sie hier studieren können.
Das heißt, gut es mag sicherlich jetzt auch die Leute geben, die einfach für sich ohnehin schon verinnerlicht haben, ich will forschen, ich will in die Wissenschaft, ich will irgendwie das maximale leisten, was es da gibt. Das ist ja dann sicherlich auch nochmal eine kleine Gruppe innerhalb der Gesamtbildung. Für die ist sagen wir mal Cambridge und Oxford allein schon deshalb interessant, weil es halt auch einfach der Ort ist, wo einfach die besten zu finden sind und wo man dann auch einfach sein will, wenn man irgendwie ganz vorne mitlaufen will. Der Rest ist, wie wir jetzt schon angedeutet haben, sozusagen dieser soziale Sog wäre ja toll, wenn man dahin kommt, weil dann geht es mir ja irgendwie gut und dann habe ich sagen wir mal auch den Status in der Gesellschaft, der hier ja auch noch sehr hoch geschätzt wird. Der vielleicht überall hoch geschätzt wird, aber der finde ich hier noch mal eine besondere Rolle spielt.
Mich erinnert das jetzt gerade, ich hatte hier in der Serie bei Forschergeist vor ein paar Ausgaben haben wir uns hier über Talentförderung explizit unterhalten mit Suhat Yilmaz von der Hochschule Gelsenkirchen, wo so ein Projekt stattfindet, wo explizit Schüler schon in den schulen früh angesprochen werden, damit sie sich das überhaupt vorstellen können. Wo diese Lücke, diese mentale Lücke geschlossen werden soll, dass die sich das überhaupt vorstellen können, dass eine Universität selbstverständlich auch ein teil des Weges sein kann. Wo man also frühzeitig Schüler anspricht und versucht, herauszufinden, können die was. Ja also auch in Zusammenarbeit mit den Lehrern. Gibt es so was ähnliches hier auch jetzt? Also ist das sozusagen ein teil dieses Versuchs, sich zu öffnen in diese Richtung vielleicht?
Ja. Also ich habe das gestartet. Das gibt es also nur in Anfängen und ich habe das selber gestartet. Eine outreach Kampagne für die Histroy Faculty. Seit vier Jahren mach ich das jetzt hier. Das Cambridge History for Schools und da laden wir meistens, also jetzt fangen wir auch an, in die schulen zu gehen. Also vor allem eben in schulen in unterprivilegierten gebieten von Cambridge und der ganzen Region. Aber sonst laden wir eben Schüler ein, also gerade die jünger sind, im alter von 7-14, dass sie zu uns kommen zu einer thematischen, themengebundenen Veranstaltung, die aber auch Spaß macht, wo sie eben mit Doktoranden oder Unidozenten eben ein Thema anschauen. Und das ist genau, da geht es genau darum, dass sie überhaupt mal den Weg finden in eine uni und merken, wie es da aussieht und dass sie da ernst genommen werden. Und dass es vorstellbar wird.
Das sind kleine schritte, aber mir ist es ein wichtiger schritt, dass wir das machen. Ich wollte noch zurückkommen darauf, was Sie vorher gesagt haben und sozusagen das darstellen, was meiner Meinung nach so fatal ist an diesem System. Sie müssen sich ja vorstellen, die meisten, die hier studieren, die werden ja nicht Wissenschaftler und die wollen das auch nicht werden, selbst wenn sie Geschichte studieren. Die machen danach so Umschulungskurse und die werden dann in der Regel Juristen. Viele gehen auch in den Medienbereich, aber im Grunde genommen gehen die entweder ins Consulting oder zu den Banken und Businesses oder eben werden Juristen. im weiteren sinne. Und das machen sie natürlich auch, weil sie da dann entsprechend Geld verdienen. Warum müssen sie entsprechend Geld verdienen? Weil sie genau das wiederholen wollen, was sie selber bekommen haben. Das heißt sie müssen genug Geld verdienen, damit sie diesen immensen Schulgebühren für ihre eigenen Kinder bezahlen können, damit sie im Süden Englands wohnen können, möglichst in London, damit sie sich da ein Haus kaufen können.
Und das wiederholt sich von Generation zu Generation. Das ist unheimlich statisch und man kann auch kein Ende sehen. Weil wiederum die Eliten sich selber ändern müssten. Warum sollen sie sich was ändern, wovon sie selber so immens profitiert haben?
Das klingt ja ein bisschen fatal.
Das ist auch fatal. Also das ist eben genau das, wo ich immer denke, Deutschland muss so stolz drauf sein, was da erreicht worden ist. Gucken wir in Amerika, also viele junge Leute, die nach Amerika kommen für ein Schuljahr sind ja oft sehr begeistert. Aber wenn man sich anguckt, wie elitär auch da das mit den immensen schulden, die da mit dem Universitätsstudium verbunden sind und dieser extremen auslese. Wir wissen alle, dass auch der Werdegang in der Schule von so vielen Faktoren und nach wie vor auch in Deutschland ganz extrem von der Herkunftsfamilie beeinflusst worden ist. Aber zumindest ist es in Deutschland wird es noch mehr aufgefangen, dadurch dass das Universitätssystem so offen ist. Und dann können Menschen sich dann tatsächlich nochmal über diese Bildung ganz andere Chancen erarbeiten. Und da muss eben meiner Meinung nach festgehalten werden und es darf eben nicht nur auf diese Beispiele von Oxford und Cambridge oder Harvard usw. geguckt werden.
Aber wenn Sie sich im Prinzip was ähnliches wünschen auch für diese Universitäten hier, was ist denn so Ihre Hoffnung, welchen Einfluss das wiederum auf das universitäre System hier haben könnte? Weil man im Prinzip bei denen dann auch genauso befürchten muss, dass wenn die das dann vielleicht tatsächlich geschafft haben, dass sie dann hier so durchmarschieren und dann wieder selber in diesem Zyklus mit, jetzt muss ich aber doch was anderes beruflich ausüben als ich gelernt habe, damit ich sozusagen das meinem nachwuchs wieder weiterreichen kann. Wie könnte man denn diesen Teufelskreis durchbrechen? Ist das da auch etwas was die Universitäten dazu beitragen können?
Ja wie gesagt, also was anderes als diese outreach Kampagnen kann ich mir im Moment nicht vorstellen. Aber da ist es eben, dass die Erfahrung zeigt immer, dass die Leute, die wir dann erreichen, das ist tatsächlich so, ich meine die dann hier studieren, nicht aus unterprivilegierten Situationen kommen, die wollen dann eigentlich auch nur viel Geld verdienen, wenn sie fertig sind, das ist wirklich so. da muss man sich auch keine falschen Vorstellungen machen.
Aber irgendjemand will doch bestimmt auch mal in dem Feld wirken, was er dann hier gelernt hat.
Wenig, also sozusagen es ist auch immer mehr so, da muss man eben dann noch dazu sagen, dass sich die Bildungslandschaft hier, seit ich angekommen bin, auch nochmal sehr verändert hat. Also es gibt zum Beispiel, als ich hier studiert habe, da konnte man direkt anschließen einen Doktor. Das geht inzwischen nicht mehr, da muss man ein Jahr ein Programm machen, das heißt M-Phil bevor man eine Doktorarbeit anfangen kann. Inzwischen gibt es sozusagen keinen, also das ist natürlich hier immer mit hohen gebühren verbunden und es gibt eigentlich überhaupt keine Stipendien mehr für dieses eine M-Phil Jahr. Und mir sagen die Studenten mehr und mehr, also auch die gut sind, wir haben jetzt schon, also nach der Einführung auch dieser gebühren für das Studium selber, wir haben unsere Eltern schon um so viel Geld gebeten und wir können ihnen einfach nicht zumuten noch mehr zu bezahlen und gleichzeitig oder sie wollen eben keine eigenen schulden.
Das ist natürlich in Amerika anders, wo schon klar ist, dass man viele schulden selber macht und die dann abbezahlt. Das heißt also, Wissenschaftler zu werden ist schon aus diesen gründen was, was tatsächlich eher eine Berufung ist. Also man muss schon sozusagen nicht anders können. Und eben im besten Fall muss man eben auch noch Eltern haben, die das bezahlen können. Also ab der Doktorarbeit ist es dann. Also wenn man herausragend ist, dann wird man sicherlich auch von den bekommen als Doktorandin oder Doktorand, aber es ist tatsächlich sehr viel schwieriger geworden, Wissenschaftlerin zu werden oder Wissenschaftler.
Das gilt jetzt nicht unbedingt nur für England jetzt gerade, was wir sagen?
Das gilt jetzt für ganz England. Also überall wurde das eingeführt mit diesen M-Phil-Kursen.
Wie heißt das genau?
M-Phil heißt das, also Master of Philosophy. Weil der Grundstudiengang ist ja nur drei Jahre zu dem BA. Dem Bachelor. Und dann ist es das eine Jahr was darauf folgt, um sich dann eben zu qualifizieren für ein PHD Doktoranden Studiengang.
Ist ganz interessant. Weil wir ja jetzt im Prinzip hier so eine Melange haben. Vielleicht um nochmal ein bisschen das englische System oder zumindest auch die Realität jetzt hier in Cambridge besser zu verstehen, würde mich nochmal interessieren, inwiefern sich jetzt die Arbeitsweise hier unterscheidet? Vielleicht nochmal kurz die zahlen, die Geschichtszahlen hier richtig zu bekommen. Also Sie waren ein Jahr in Cambridge, dann ging es zurück, da ist das Studium dann auch zu Ende geführt worden in den drei verschiedenen Kategorien? Und dann?
Dann war es tatsächlich so, dass für mich dieses eine Jahr in Cambridge deshalb so prägend war, weil ich zum ersten mal das Gefühl hatte, dass ich richtig ernst genommen werden. Also man hatte hier eben, also das funktioniert so, dass man jede Woche ein Essay schreibt zu einem Thema und den einreicht. Also das sind ungefähr 2000 Worte zu einem Thema und dieses bespricht man dann eine stunde lang mit den Professoren und Dozenten. Und in diesen Gesprächen tatsächlich ernst genommen zu werden von Spezialisten in ihrem fach war für mich eben einschneidend als Erfahrung. Und zum ersten mal hatte ich da eben auch das Gefühl, ich möchte Historikerin werden.
Und das fehlte vorher, dieses ernst genommen werden?[00:34:20.1 @ulinkarublak>Ja, also das wiederum in Deutschland ich würde sagen vielleicht von einem Professor, aber das war einfach sozusagen einfach kaum machbar auf der ebene. Sie müssen sich immer vorstellen, ich bin ja sehr früh weggegangen, ich hatte ja erst drei Semester studiert. Wie gesagt, ich hatte ja auch noch viel zu lernen. Also es war auch schwierig, diese Erfahrung zu haben. Aber hier ist es tatsächlich sehr charakteristisch, dass sozusagen jeder wird ernst genommen, natürlich auch wiederum qua Auswahl. Also man kriegt dieses doch sehr große Angebot geschenkt. Ich bin wirklich daran interessiert, was du denkst als Student. Du könntest auch was hochinteressantes sagen und wir entwickeln das durch dieses Gespräch. Also der Professor oder der sonstige Dozent, die nehmen sich wirklich eben Zeit vom Erstsemester sich eine halbe stunde vorher diesen Essay durchzulesen und den zu annotieren.
Also ganz grundlegend zu kommentieren im Idealfall und dann eben eine weitere stunde, also die investieren wirklich 1,5 stunden in diesen Student. der Erstsemestler sein kann.
Woran liegt das? Also ist das jetzt ein Abfallprodukt der englischen Gesellschaft und des gepflegten Miteinanders, was man hier vorfindet? Oder ist das einfach nur der Aspekt, dass hier die Auswahlkriterien schon so stark sind, dass man mit dieser kleineren Gruppe von vornherein anders arbeitet und ein ganz anderes Zeitmanagement hat?
Eben also letzteres auf jeden Fall, aber natürlich kommt das auch mit rein, dass denke ich ist schon dann wiederum ein großer Vorteil von der englischen Vorstellung von Gespräch als was was Zeit braucht, wo eben auch von dass man nicht unbedingt Experte sein muss, um auf originelle Ideen zu kommen, das denke ich ist sehr charakteristisch. Ist sehr viel weniger hierarchisch. Also das ist das entscheidende. Also in Deutschland geht natürlich alles sehr stark auch immer noch, hat sich ein bisschen verbessert und ist kollegialer geworden, aber die Hierarchien sind nach wie vor extrem prägend und auch Altershierarchien und das ist in England sehr viel weniger ausgeprägt.
Ja naja nicht so richtig. Also das kann man so nicht sagen. Also die sind sehr viel flacher die Hierarchien.
Im Englischen fällt das ja zwangsläufig bei ab.
Naja wir haben Vornamen, also eben dass auch die, also ich bin hier in Cambridge und am sankt Johns College sind natürlich alle mögliche, also wenn man anfängt, sind auch alle möglichen Koryphäen des faches. Also die sind alle sehr, also so dieses, dass man sich aufbläht und immer der eigenen Wirkung und des eigenen Wirkens bewusst ist, das spielt hier überhaupt keine Rolle. Also da wird eher so runter geschaut auf Leute, die immer so wichtig tun.
Weniger Gegockel?
Weniger Gegockel eindeutig. Einfach weil es hier natürlich auch so viele, ich meine im College nebenan da gibt es mehr Nobelpreisträger als in ganz Frankreich zusammen. Also ich meine was sollen die alle wichtig tun? Und es wird aber auch davon ausgegangen, dass wenn man auch im alter von 60 vielleicht nochmal eine entscheidende Idee haben kann. Also es wird alles sehr viel lockerer gesehen. Aber wie gesagt, dass Leute sich nun wichtig machen und aufspielen, das gibt es hier eigentlich kaum.
Ich bin nur ein bisschen überrascht, weil ich meine das ist nicht unbedingt so das Bild von England, was man so im Kopf hat vielleicht. Geprägt durch Adel und Stände und Mehrschichten Gesellschaftssystem, was ja auch noch eine sehr starke Rolle spielt, würde man ja irgendwie erst mal erwarten, dass sich das letztlich auch nur einem Lehrsystem gerade an so einer Eliteuniversität nochmal extra manifestiert, aber dem ist nicht so?
Nein, dem ist wirklich überhaupt nicht so. Cambridge hat sich natürlich auch selber sehr geändert. Also viele Filme transportieren eigentlich immer noch so dieses mythische Bild der Auserwählten und es ist ja inzwischen so, dass es wirklich nur nach "merit" geht. Also man muss einfach diese Abiturnoten haben, sonst kommt man hier nicht rein und keiner kommt hier rein, weil der Vater schon da war usw. und von daher denke ich ist das dann doch sehr egalitär, wenn man erst mal drin ist.
Das heißt eine hohe Hürde, um sich sozusagen überhaupt erst mal zu qualifizieren, aber ab da ist dann viel Flausch?
Viel Flausch. Also man wird sofort eben auch, also die Colleges, also bieten einem völlige Identität an und sagen, du bist jetzt einfach teil und für den Rest deines Lebens wirst du eben teil von uns sein und da kannst du sozusagen gar nichts falsch machen und wir vertrauen dir und wir glauben, dass du großes leisten kannst. Und das Gefühl hatte ich in Deutschland natürlich nie. Also in Deutschland hatte ich schon, also gerade in den Geisteswissenschaften also manchmal eben tatsächlich eher das Gefühl, dass man irgendwie noch einer ist und eher so ein bisschen stört oder was will man jetzt noch, eben weil die Dozenten so überfordert waren. Und das ist hier sehr sehr entlastend für alle. Andererseits sind es natürlich auch hohe Erwartungen, also der Examenstress ist natürlich hier auch ein großes Thema. Das ist dann wiederum eben verschulter, dass eben tatsächlich alle diese Examen am Jahresende schreiben. Also ich möchte das auch nicht idealisieren. Aber tatsächlich ein sehr anderes System.
Es gab wohl eine ziemliche Welle von Deutschen, die nach England gegangen sind in den letzten Jahrzehnten. Lässt sich das hier bestätigen? Gilt das auch für Cambridge? Sind hier viele deutsche Kollegen?
Doch schon einige. Also die Welle kam glaube ich auch so ein bisschen eher nach mir dann. Ist ja auch immer wieder Thema in den deutschen Medien, warum gehen die Leute weg? Ist natürlich so, also das trifft auch da wieder zu, dass also die stellen werden natürlich also sagen wir mal, in meinem Fall war es so, dass mein Professor dann eben, Robert Scribna, der ging dann nach Harvard und seine stelle wurde dann aber eben auf einem niedrigsten Niveau eben ausgeschrieben. Es gibt hier einfach so das was wir Mittelbau nennen in Deutschland, der ist hier eben sehr sehr breit und das sind dann aber schon Stellen auf Lebenszeit. Und die werden auch nicht und das sind während in Deutschland eben die Mittelbauer eben auch in so eine Hierarchie eingebaut sind, wo sie eben sehr niedrig rangieren, ist man hier wiederum also das fängt dann eben an, was dann University electra heißt wird einem schon wiederum auch alles Vertrauen gegeben. Also mir wurden sofort fünf Doktoranden angeboten, obwohl ich gerade erst mit meiner eigenen Doktorarbeit fertig war.
Also ich bin sehr jung in dieses System reingekommen. Ich war erst 29 als ich meine erste feste Universitätsstelle hier bekam und hatte mir das vorher nie vorgestellt und dachte, ich gehe nach Deutschland zurück, um da eine Habilitation zu machen. Ich war nicht an so viel. Und dann war es einfach so, dass diese Stelle ausgeschrieben wurde, ich hatte hier am College vorher eine Forschungsstelle für zwei Jahre und dann habe ich die angenommen. Und seitdem bin ich nicht weggegangen, eben weil dann doch die Forschungsbedingungen hier attraktiver sind.
Aber das war jetzt sozusagen noch die Professorenstelle, die Sie jetzt einnehmen?
Nein, das ist eben man fängt an mit University Lecturer und dann muss man sich sozusagen immer auf die nächste stufe bewerben. Das ist wie in den Staaten. Aber man kann eben, das ist anders als in Deutschland, und auch sehr viel familienfreundlicher, man kann natürlich, also man bleibt normalerweise an der selben Universität und kann sich das dann eben einteilen. Gerade wenn man Kinder möchte zum Beispiel als Frau, kann man sich sagen, okay ich will jetzt richtig durchpowern und dann möchte ich den Karriereschritt erreichen, bevor ich Kinder habe oder man sagt, ich will nicht durchpowern und dann bleibe ich eben University Lecturer bis an mein Lebensende und bekomme das Gehalt, das kann man auch. Also es zwingt einen keiner dazu, Professorin zu werden. Und das finde ich auch sehr angenehm.
Was ändert sich denn dann dadurch noch? Also wenn man schon vorher so gut situiert ist, oder sagen wir mal auch akzeptiert ist. Also wo auch die Rolle eine Bedeutung hat, weil das ist so das, was ich hier so ein bisschen rauslese, dass man eigentlich auch häufig im deutschen System ist immer so dieses, man muss schon irgendwie eine Professur erreichen, weil sonst war es das irgendwie alles nicht und man dümpelt halt so ein bisschen in diesem Mittelbau rum. Ich höre das jetzt hier so raus, dass in dem Moment, wo man auch schon Lecturer ist, dass das dann nur noch eine Nuance ist, die dann zu dem Einnehmen einer Professur ist.?
Also natürlich ist es ein öffentliches Zeichen der Wertschätzung, dass man wirklich international als führender Wissenschaftler oder Wissenschaftlerin angesehen wird. Das heißt natürlich, also da gibt es ja bestimmte verfahren und dann werden eben viele gutachten eingeholt und so weiter, also ist schon sozusagen relativ schwierig, eine Professur zu bekommen und das signalisiert das, dass die Forschung eben wirklich so hoch angesehen wird. Dann ist das natürlich auch mit einem sehr viel höheren Gehalt verbunden und es ist jetzt in meinem Fall, das hängt aber auch vom College ab, in meinem Fall ist es damit verbunden, dass man wählen kann, ob man nach wie vor so viele Studenten betreuen will jetzt für diese undergraduated Essays und die wirklich sehr viel Zeit einnehmen. Ob man das sechs stunden die Woche machen will oder zwei stunden, das ist der unterschied.
In Deutschland stellt sich ja auch immer die Frage, Forschung und/oder Lehre. Also eigentlich Professur insbesondere hat ja eigentlich an seinem Revers stehen, ja ich forsche auch. Ich bin in der Wissenschaft, ich wage das neue. Und häufig sehen sich Professoren ja auch in dem Spannungsfeld, auf der einen Seite dieser zwang zur Drittmittelwerbung, um überhaupt auch die finanzielle Basis sicherzustellen, sowohl für die eigene Arbeit als eben auch als Mithelfer für alle. Weil ja auch die Unis in zunehmendem Maße auf diese Drittmittelflüsse angewiesen sind und die Forschung, die dann nach der lehre sozusagen dann auch noch stattfinden soll, kommt dann nicht selten auch zu kurz oder steht zumindest gefühlt nicht so im Mittelpunkt. Wie ist das Verhältnis hier zwischen Forschung und Lehre?
Ja also es ist natürlich auch immer ein riesiger Konflikt für alle, das so hinzukriegen. Also alle Leute, die hier arbeiten sind natürlich hier, weil sie aus Leidenschaft forschen. Und aus Leidenschaft lehre machen. Also das ist hier ein extremes Ethos, wie ich sagte, weil Studenten so ernst genommen werden. Also man verbringt wirklich sehr viel Zeit mit denen, auch mit Doktoranden, also die dinge, die man eben immer noch aus Deutschland hört, dass Doktoranden, also dass da nicht jedes Kapitel gelesen wird, das ist hier unvorstellbar. All das nimmt sehr großen Raum ein. Dann ist es so, wie auch in meinem eigenen Fall, dass man eben oft sehr früh anfängt. Das heißt man überhaupt nicht diese Zeit wie in Deutschland, wo die Leute im Grunde genommen frühestens mit 35 eine Professur haben und davor eben dann eine lange Forschungszeit haben. Das fällt hier auch weg. Und das macht es auch schwierig. Dann gibt es noch bestimmte Stipendien, auf die man sich bewerben kann, da gibt es sehr wenig.
Das heißt im Grunde genommen ist es hier auch so, dass man auf einerseits die Forschungsfreisemester oder Trimester vielmehr, hier ist ja nach Trimestern alles eingeteilt, das heißt das ist auch kürzer, auf diese angewiesen ist. Und die gibt es hier also alle sechs Trimester bekommt man ein Trimester, das muss man sich dann ein bisschen aufsparen, damit es länger wird, aber was ich jetzt doch zunehmend als den Hauptunterschied sehe ist, dass die Trimester gerade in Cambridge sind sie wirklich sehr kurz, das heißt es sind acht Wochen, also von Oktober bis Anfang Dezember, dann nochmal acht Wochen von Mitte Januar bis Mitte März und dann das dritte Trimester ist eigentlich dieses Examenssemester, wo wenig Lehre gemacht wird, eher so Revision. also wo Wissen wiederholt wird mit den Studenten und dann eben die Examenskorrekturen laufen.
Und dazwischen sind eben diese vorlesungsfreien Zeiten länger als in Deutschland und die werden auch weitgehend respektiert. Das heißt man hat im Grunde genommen schon drei Monate im Jahr, die man wirklich für Forschung aufwenden kann, so kann man das sehen, wenn man alles andere abzieht, was sonst noch so ist, bleiben im Grunde genommen schon drei Monate irgendwie über. Kommt drauf an, wie lange man Urlaub macht. Und dafür leben wir natürlich für diese Zeit. Aber es ist schon, natürlich ist es für alle ein riesiges Problem und natürlich auch deswegen, weil wiederum seit ich nach England gekommen bin hat sich das auch extrem geändert. Also wir werden eben inzwischen alle sieben Jahre evaluiert und da muss man eben nachweisen, was man geforscht hat und das spielt inzwischen eine immense Rolle auch eben für den Status der Universität, aber auch für das eigene Ansehen.
Dass man da eben gut abschneidet. Also im unterschied zu Deutschland, wo ich eben merke, das ist tatsächlich für viele Professoren ist es ganz schwierig, noch Forschungsmonografien zu schreiben. Müssen wir das hier quasi. Also alle sieben Jahre ist schon das ideal, dass es eine Forschungsmonografie gibt und zwei Artikel in führenden Zeitschriften. Dann ist wichtig geworden, dass man nachweisen kann, dass die eigene Forschung auch was bewegt hat, dass sie Leute erreicht, also was Impact genannt wird. Und es ist zunehmend wichtig auch da, dass man Forschungsgelder angeworben hat und Stellen geschaffen hat für Doktoranden und Postdoktoranden, das ist hier auch.
Das heißt auch die Drittmittelzwänge existieren hier auch im selben Maße?
Das kann ich nicht so ganz beurteilen.
Oder in welchem Maße?[00:49:21.5 @ulinkarublak>Also ich möchte nur sagen, dass ist auch in anderen Universitäten in England war das schon früher stärker, aber hier ist es inzwischen würde ich sagen, so in den letzten vier Jahren ist es doch sehr sehr klar gemacht worden, also vor allem so in der nächsten Generation, dass man zum Beispiel auch darüber dann die Promotion, also wie sagt man das, die Beförderungen auch daran gekoppelt sind und das ist wiederum sehr ähnlich wie in Deutschland. Dass man Forschungsgelder einwirbt und das ist natürlich sehr sehr zwiespältig und sehr problematisch.
Evaluation der Forschung basiert dann auf was? Paper?[00:50:04.7 @ulinkarublak>Nein, das sind eben Monografien in der Geschichte nach wie vor.
Okay, das ist jetzt geschichtsspezifisch.
Ja genau. Also idealerweise sollte man eben eine Monografie haben und das ist sehr viel alle sieben Jahre.
Was kann man sich darunter vorstellen?[00:50:18.0 @ulinkarublak>Also ein Buch. Und dann eben noch zwei Artikel in führenden, also die wiederum auf nicht synthetisierend sind, also keine überblicksartige, sondern wirklich auf Forschung beruhen und wirklich was neues sagen. Also die werden dann eben danach evaluiert, die sind sollen eben international führend sein auch. Oder sie sind dann nur von nationaler Bedeutung.
In Ihrem Fall war das jetzt die Geschichte von Keppler, die vorhin schon zur Sprache kam?
Na das wird jetzt mein neues Buch sein für den nächsten Zyklus, für den letzten Zyklus war das Buch, was ich geschrieben habe, woran ich zehn Jahre gearbeitet habe, eben neben allem anderen, über die Geschichte der Kleidung und vor allem der Identität in der frühen Neuzeit. Und dann habe ich herausgegeben ein Buch über Geschichtsmethodik, wo ich versucht habe, aufzuzeigen, wie wichtig es ist, in weltgeschichtlichen Horizonten zu denken. Das waren so die wichtigsten Publikationen. Jetzt habe ich eben das Buch abgeschlossen über Johannes Keppler und den Hexereivorwurf gegen seine Mutter. Soll ich da kurz ein bisschen drüber erzählen?
Ja gerne.
Die Geschichte ist sehr spannend. Im Jahr 1615 also genau vor 400 Jahren bekommt Keppler, der gerade auf der Höhe seines Ruhmes steht als Astronom und dabei ist, sein Hauptwerk die Harmonie der Welt, abzuschließen, bekommt er einen Brief der Schwester und in dem steht eben, dass die Mutter wegen Hexerei angeklagt ist. Und daraus entwickelt sich ein Hexereiprozess, der sechs Jahre dann dauert und in dem Keppler selber die Verteidigung rechtlich übernimmt. Das ist der einzige Fall, in dem ein intellektueller sich je so involviert hat für verwandte und die Dokumentation ist herausragend. Also wir haben sowohl die ganzen Prozessakten. Keppler schreibt auch sehr viel über sich. Ist psychologisch also hochinteressant als Mensch und natürlich als Wissenschaftler sehr komplex.
Und das spielt alles in Leonberg bei Stuttgart. Und auch da ist die Archivlage herausragend, also wir können sehr viel über diesen Ort raus finden. Also Gerichtsakten usw. und so fort. Die Beziehungen der Menschen untereinander lassen sich sehr gut rekonstruieren und das habe ich eben für diese Publikation aufgearbeitet.
Wie leicht zugreifbar sind denn diese hervorragenden Dokumente? Man muss schon hinfahren?
Ja man muss hinfahren. Aber das geht ja sehr leicht mit den deutschen Nahverkehrsmöglichkeiten.
Na gut, aber es ist noch nicht alles digitalisiert, das ist das was ich meine.
Nein, also die Prozessakten. selber sind inzwischen digitalisiert. Die waren schon mal rausgegeben, das würde ich auch jedem empfehlen, das ist ganz spannend, das nachzulesen. Wer sich damit auseinandersetzen möchte. Die frisch rausgegebenen werke von Keppler. Und Kepplers werke sind auch digitalisiert, das stimmt. Von der Kepler-Kommission in München. Also zu meisten teilen, noch nicht alles, aber das meiste, und dann der teil, der dazu kommt, ist eben vor allem natürlich habe ich mir andere Hexerei im Hauptstadtarchiv Stuttgart habe ich mir andere Hexereiprozesse aus der Zeit angeschaut zum Vergleich, um das überhaupt einordnen zu können. Und dann habe ich eben in Leonberg im Archiv gearbeitet, um diese Gerichtsakten und weitere Akten über die gemeinde anzuschauen.
Hexerei sind das nicht im wesentlichen politische Prozesse gewesen? Also heute würde man sie wahrscheinlich so nennen oder? Oder glaubte das ...?
Wie kommen Sie drauf?[00:54:03.2 @timpritlove>Weiß nicht, weil ich meine, es ist schwer, sich vorzustellen, dass Leute das wirklich geglaubt haben, weil irgendwelche Anhaltspunkte müssten sie ja dann erst mal haben und ich bezweifele halt einfach mal stark, dass irgendjemand hat irgendjemand anders hat hexen sehen. Also muss ja der Vorwurf irgendwo herkommen und nicht selten war das natürlich auch ein mittel, um Leute zu diskreditieren, indem man das halt einfach erst mal auf den Tisch geworfen hat und dann mussten die sich damit rumschlagen.
Ja aber die haben das ja selber erfahren. Also muss man ja ernst nehmen, dass deren Erfahrungsweise tatsächlich war, dass sie nicht mehr gehen konnten. Die Logik ist ja immer die, es war ja nicht so, als ob die Leute leichter Hand zu diesem Vorwurf gegriffen haben und sie wussten ja auch, dass man krank werden kann, aus natürlichen Ursachen. Und das war aber jeweils dann so, also sagen wir mal, ein Baby starb, das war völlig normal, 99% der fälle hat niemand an Hexerei gedacht, aber wenn es dreimal vorkam, dass ein Baby starb und noch dazu lief es blau an in einer Art und weise, in der das nie geschah. Und dann war es noch so gewesen, dass eine Frau das Baby angeguckt hatte und sehr merkwürdig gesagt hat, oh das ist aber ein hübsches Baby usw. und so fort. Da wurde eben da dann die Ansammlung von Beweisstücken als doch Verdachtsmoment gesehen.
Und wie hat Keppler sich dann da geschlagen so als Wissenschaftler?[00:55:32.7 @ulinkarublak>Also Keppler hat natürlich auch Hexerei geglaubt. Also man muss jetzt erst mal davon ausgehen, dass in diesen Jahrhunderten fast alle an Hexerei geglaubt haben, die Frage war eben, wie man das erklärte. Und da haben sich die Leute, da gab es unterschiedliche Sichtweisen. Luthertum jetzt vor allem in Wittenberg war es eben wo, dass man gesagt hat, es ist so, dass der Teufel, an den natürlich alle glaubten, der Teufel gibt diese Vorstellung ein den Frauen ein, dass sie diese Macht haben, dass sie andere verletzen können und schädigen können. Das heißt man konnte rechtlich diese Frauen auch hinrichten, weil sie eben vom Glauben an Gott abgefallen sind und sich dem Teufel verschrieben haben.
Die haben nicht geglaubt, dass die tatsächlich, also das war die eigentliche Lehre dann er Theologen und Juristen, also die sagten offiziell, also dass sie nicht glauben, dass sie wirklich diesen Schaden ausführen können, sondern dass der Teufel ihnen diese Illusion eingibt. Andere haben gesagt, ja also auf jeden Fall, die können wirklich Kinder töten und wenn der Teufel ihnen diese salbe gibt, da stimmt alles und können diesen schrecklichen Schaden anrichten. Man muss sich vorstellen, das war eine Zeit, die auch die kleine Eiszeit genannt wird. Also Missernten, schreckliches Wetter oft, und es kam den Leuten so vor, diese schrecklichen Hagelwetter, als ob die wirklich von den hexen verursacht worden wären. Die Schäden waren immens. Die Hungerjahre und so haben die das auch versucht, zu erklären.
Wie gesagt nicht alle und nicht gleich, aber doch immer wieder kam die Frage auf, wenn also die Schäden sind so schrecklich, was wir erleben, wenn es auch nur die Möglichkeit gibt, dass es an den hexen liegt, dann müssen wir auch dagegen was unternehmen. Und dann kamen natürlich wieder die zweifel auf, also deshalb hat man oft so Wellenbewegungen von anklagen. Also eben in den Jahren, wo man eher denkt, ja wenn es sein könnte, dann müssen wir jetzt handeln. Und dann wieder die Jahre, in der viel Kritik geäußert wurde am verfahren, in der gesagt wurde, wie wurde da jetzt eigentlich genau ermittelt? Wer war denn jetzt genau zeuge? Gibt es genug rechtlichen Schutz für diese Frauen meistens. Also 70% der angeklagten waren eben Frauen, die anderen waren auch Männer. Deshalb hatte Keppler auch mit so angst, selber angeklagt zu werden als Sohn. So gestaltete sich das.
Klingt spannend.
Ja das war auch sehr spannend.
Um nochmal so ein bisschen zurückzukommen auf, was man so ein bisschen ableiten kann aus den Erfahrungen hier in England und auch jetzt gerade so in der Mischung auch den Erfahrungen in Deutschland. Denken ja alle immer so ein bisschen darüber nach. Was muss man jetzt eigentlich ändern? Also ich meine, so eine allgemeine Unzufriedenheit herrscht ja immer vor, das ist ja auch gut so, weil wenn es das nicht gäbe, dann würde sich ja gar nichts ändern können. Und so oder so finden Änderungen statt, weil ja dann letztlich auch das akademische System ein Spiegel dieser Gesellschaft ist und die Prioritäten sich am laufenden Meter ändern. Also auf der einen Seite ändert sich eigentlich ganz schön viel, auf der anderen Seite ändert sich nicht genug, oder vielleicht nicht das richtige. Jetzt hat man hier, wenn ich das richtig rauslese so ein bisschen den Vorteil des privilegierten Ortes.
Der durch seinen aufgeladenen Status auch über die entsprechenden finanziellen mittel verfügt, um sagen wir mal eine Lehre auch so zu machen, wie man das eben für richtig hält. Oder wo man eben auch gesehen hat, ah das funktioniert ja alles viel besser und alle sind glücklicher und froher, wenn man das irgendwie so macht. Das heißt man hier den Raum zu experimentieren mit dem verfahren. Auf der anderen Seite hat man jetzt in Deutschland dann wiederum zwar den Nachteil, dass man eben nicht im selben Maße über solche mittel verfügt, weil der Anspruch ein anderer ist, weil man eben sehr viel breiter abdecken will, weil man eben eine Bildung für alle Systeme durchziehen will, was eben explizit sich nicht auf solche Eliten beschränkt.
Frage ich mich natürlich, wie kann man diese Erfahrungen zusammenbringen? Also was ist sozusagen das, was man jetzt hier aus diesem wie es eigentlich laufen sollte, so dass es gut ist auch für die Forschung und das Studium als solche, mit dem anderen Anspruch, das möglichst breit in die Gesellschaft zu tragen. Gibt es da bei Ihnen irgendwelche Erkenntnisse, was man da vielleicht mal beherzigen sollte?
Also was meinen Sie jetzt genau mit, was möglichst breit in die Gesellschaft zu tragen?
Also überhaupt die Lehre. Man möchte ja sozusagen große Teile der Gesellschaft mit maximal guter Bildung versorgen, aber irgendwann reichen dann halt eben die Ressourcen dafür nicht. Und klar jetzt kann man natürlich immer nach mehr Geld, mehr Geld, mehr Geld schreien, aber das ist natürlich auch nur begrenzt vorhanden. Beziehungsweise weil man nicht die richtigen Argumente ins Feld führt, dann ist es natürlich auch schwierig, so was freizueisen. Aber wenn man jetzt auf der anderen Seite ein bisschen hier in diesem kleinen Paradies  ich überhöhe das jetzt etwas  sozusagen sieht, okay wenn man jetzt solche Voraussetzungen hat, was macht man denn dann eigentlich besser und anders? Vielleicht ließe sich das eine oder andere auch im deutschen Kontext umsetzen, man sieht es bloß derzeit noch nicht, weil man sich irgendwie mit anderen Sachen beschäftigt.
Also ich sage mal diese Hierarchiearmut oder das weniger starke Durchdringen von Hierarchie ist ja nicht so, dass sich so was nicht auf ein anderes System übertragen ließe, selbst wenn, es ist ja nicht so sehr vom Geld abhängig.
Also das denke ich auf jeden Fall. Also stärke ... Kollegialsystem heißt das glaube ich. Also das auch interdisziplinär und insgesamt einfach klar ist, Status ist nicht so wichtig, gerade junge Leute haben sehr oft sehr extrem kreative Ideen, aber die müssen sich natürlich entfalten können, da gehört ja auch Mut dazu. Und dass man dem Raum schafft, also dass man sozusagen gar nicht so anfängt mit der Vorstellung, dass man alles weiß oder überhaupt schon das wichtigste weiß, also eher so auf die Studenten zugeht mit dem Eindruck, die können mehr wissen als man selber. Die können auf Ideen kommen, auf die man selber eben gar nicht kommt. Und dass man das zum tragen bringt und dafür auch die entsprechende Atmosphäre schafft. Aber ich glaube, was auch oft nicht gesehen wird ist, den doch nach wie vor sehr eigenen Status, den Universitäten brauchen, wenn sie tatsächlich dem Kreativen Raum geben wollen.
Also sowohl hier als auch in Deutschland, also es braucht diese akademische Freiheit, die immer mehr beschränkt worden ist, sowohl hier als auch dort. Und die nährt sich eben nicht davon, dass sie Anträge schreibt auf diese Drittmittelförderung, sondern sie macht sie immer kleiner, und das tut den Menschen nicht gut und das hat ja vor allem die Konsequenz, dass man weiß, man wird auch von Kollegen immer weiter evaluiert. Also das ist meiner Meinung nach das ausschlaggebende, dass es wesentlich weniger Risikofreude und wesentlich weniger Debatten gibt. Weil wenn ich mich auf diese Drittmittellogik einlasse, hier wie dort, dann ist ja klar, eben bis ich meine Karriere abschließe mache ich immer wieder Anträge und ich weiß ja nie, von wem die evaluiert werden.
Oder wenn auch mit dieser Forschungsevaluierung, ich weiß ja, das werden immer irgendwelche Kollegen sein, also ist die beste Strategie natürlich, dass ich so wenig kontrovers wie möglich bin, weil es könnte ja dann immer jemand sein, der dann sofort meine Anträge blockiert.
Also kontrovers im Sinne von den formulierten Forschungszielen.
Genau. Und also diese Situation haben wir jetzt. Das merkt man immer, wenn man schon in dem, was man den Studenten dann zu lesen gibt, also in den 70er und 80er Jahren da gab es nur diese riesigen kontroversen, Marxismus und ganz andere Debatten, die dann sehr spannend waren. Was sind denn jetzt eigentlich die großen Debatten. Keiner traut sich mehr aus diesen Gründen. Und wie gesagt, solange auch das Einkommen immer dran gekoppelt wird, dass man immer mehr von diesen Anträgen durchkriegt, wird das keiner tun. Also das muss meiner Meinung nach alles zurückgefahren werden und auf eine ganz andere Vorstellung von akademischer Freiheit rekurriert werden. Die eben auch viel von dem beinhaltet, was wir früher hier ganz stark hatten, was wir noch ein bisschen haben, also was man eben Serendipity nennen könnte.
Also es gibt ja tatsächlich eben, wir haben unseren Garten, wo wir Cricket spielen, macht keiner mehr. So das war teil der Kultur früher und die Idee wiederum, dass eben da die Ideen kommen und die Gespräche entstehen.
Es wird nicht mehr Cricket gespielt in Cambridge?
Oder Croquet vielmehr. Croquet Garden, aber es gibt eben Gärten. Also es ist auch eine sehr ästhetische Lebensweise hier. Wir haben einen Garten, wir essen sehr gepflegt zusammen, nehmen uns dafür Zeit. Das ist wiederum sehr spezifisch für Cambridge. Und genau da ist es eben so, dass was neues entstehen kann. Ich gebe Ihnen ein Beispiel jetzt hier am College ist es auch so, jedes College hat eine Kirche, wobei es absolut nicht verpflichtend ist, zu dem Service hinzugehen. Aber in unserem Fall haben wir eben auch einen eigenen Chor, also einen Knabenchor, der mitfinanziert wird, der sehr berühmt ist, sankt Johns Choir. Und was ich mir jetzt überlegt habe und wofür ich 25.000 Pfund bekommen habe vom College ist, es gibt zwei Opern über Keppler, eine von Philip Glas und eine von Hindemith.
Und Hindemith. Im besonderen stellt die Geschichte der Mutter sehr problematisch dar und ich habe mir gedacht, ich möchte eigentlich ein Gegenstück komponieren lassen und arbeite am College, haben wir auch, dadurch dass wir Musiker haben, haben wir einen sehr guten Komponisten, Timothy Watts und der hat eben Geld bekommen für 14 Minuten zu komponieren, aber das wird entstehen auch in Gesprächen mit mir und Kollegen, die Keplerexperten sind, die zu anderen Musiktheorie der Zeit, wo wir wirklich ganz neue Art von Wissen kreieren können, was dann musisch umgesetzt wird und wir werden auch mit einer Videokünstlerin zusammen arbeiten und das kann hier entstehen, das wird dann natürlich auch meine wissenschaftliche Einsicht wiederum befruchten auch. Also sich wirklich durch diese Gespräche nochmal anders damit auseinanderzusetzen. Was können wir eigentlich über die stimme zum Beispiel von Katharina Keppler sagen? Wie können wir uns der historisch nähern?
Das ist die Mutter?
Das ist die Mutter ja. Also es gibt in dem Sinne, wenn man Wissenschaft eben nicht eng versteht, sondern eben als was, was eine eigene Kultur bedarf und schöpfen kann.
Und auch Kultur schafft.
Und auch Kultur schafft natürlich. Denn woher soll sonst .. - also wiederum auch deshalb macht für mich natürlich diese Trennung zwischen Gegenwart und Geschichte so wenig Sinn, wenn wir Kultur anschauen, rekurriert sie also stark auf historisches Wissen. Also sagen wie Philip Glas, der Einstein als Oper gemacht hat, wird eben gefragt, wenn Linz Kulturhauptstadt wird, wird der eben angefragt, würden Sie eine Oper machen über Keppler? Ja, auf was soll er denn zurückgreifen. Es gibt eine extreme Spezialforschung, die wirklich zu komplex ist. Überall sind wir umgeben von Kulturschaffenden, die natürlich dann auf, was soll er sich Wikipedia angucken, da sind eben nur Teile drin und deshalb ist es ja so wichtig. Und es gibt natürlich ein immenses Publikum, was von Keppler fasziniert ist. Figuren wie Galileo und so weiter. Leute wollen ja darüber Bescheid wissen, wie sie das einordnen sollen.
Und Städte sind stolz auf jemanden wie Keppler, der in ihnen gelebt hat. Und in dem sinne ist eben meiner Meinung nach ganz extrem darauf zu bestehen, dass wir nie eine Logik im engeren sinne von Wirtschaftlichkeit folgen sollten. Sondern die akademische Freiheit brauchen, um zu überleben. Und das muss verstanden werden.
Eine zweite Sache, die mir noch aufgefallen ist, die ich aber jetzt noch nicht so vollständig verstanden habe, aber in Cambridge gibt es auch sehr viele Möglichkeiten für die Studenten auf dem Campus auch zu wohnen.
Im College ja.
Im College. Also die haben hier sozusagen ihre Wohnräume?
Ja die haben Wohnungen. Also nicht Wohnungen., sondern die haben zimmer, was sie sich dann teilweise wenn es größer ist auch teilen. Deshalb sind dann die zahlen auch so begrenzt. Weil wie gesagt, man kann sich bei der Universität Cambridge bewerben und Geschichte studieren. Man muss sich an einem College, man muss sich das College aussuchen und wir nehmen zum Beispiel um die acht Studenten. Also jedes College nimmt jedes Jahr acht Studenten für ein bestimmtes fach auf. Und es werden ungefähr 40 interviewt im Idealfall und da wird man eben entsprechend ausgewählt oder nicht. Und dann hat man hier das zimmer und dann geht man zur Fakultät und hört Vorlesungen, man wird aber auch unterrichtet in ein Büros von Dozenten, die dann in den verschiedenen Colleges sind. Und man hat auch einen teil des Unterrichts eben nur im College.
Das schafft natürlich eine gewisse Nähe. Ist das etwas, was sich, wenn ich das jetzt nochmal ganz ketzerisch versuche, auf die  wie soll man das denn überhaupt nennen  Massenuniversität trifft es ja jetzt auch nicht, größer breiter angelegten Universitäten Deutschlands übertragen. Fehlt denen Universitäten dort diese Nähe? Oder ist das etwas, in was man in irgendeiner Form investieren könnte?
Aber ich meine jetzt auch so die Wohnsituation.
Die Wohnsituation. Also ich meine das ist also, ob man solche Kollegstrukturen in Deutschland möchte. Also ich meine es muss ja nun auch nicht, also es hat bestimmte Vorteile, aber also ehrlich gesagt, das finde ich nun in Deutschland auch sehr angenehm an dieser Lebensphase, dass man da dann eigenständig leben kann und also auch Erfahrungen macht ganz anderer Art. die nicht nur im College sind. Also das hat natürlich dieses sehr gemeinschaftsorientierte, aber ob man das nun unbedingt oder ob das überhaupt übersetzungsfähig wäre, das weiß ich jetzt nicht. Aber daran liegt es auch nicht. Ich glaube das liegt wirklich wesentlich daran an diesen, dass man sich auch als teil der Tutorengruppe, dass man merkt, da ist eben wirklich jemand, der ist an einem interessiert. Und der guckt nicht auf einen runter oder der denkt nicht, man weiß gar nichts.
Sondern der nimmt einen ernst, die nimmt einen ernst und wird das Studium begleiten. Das ist das Grundprinzip hier. Und glaube wer braucht das wirklich, wenn die Motivationslagen eben bei den Studentinnen und Studenten selber stimmt.
Das heißt am Ende lese ich schon so ein wenig ein Plädoyer eigentlich für den Mittelbau heraus.
Also das ist nicht das, was sich jetzt hier immer wieder abzeichnet, dass es gar nicht so sehr eine Frage von Professorenstellen ist, sicherlich teilweise auch, aber auch wahrscheinlich nur deshalb, weil das eben der traditionelle Ort ist, wo die Doktoranden andocken, wo es sich sozusagen organisiert, während es sich hier schon auf einer niedrigeren ebene sehr viel selbstständiger organisiert, auf einem ganz anderen Hierarchielevel schon breit, auch in die Studentenschaft hineinwirken kann.
Ja.
Ja auf jeden Fall. Und dass man wirklich nochmal diese ziele überprüft. Also was will man denn eigentlich? Also nicht so diesen Trend fördern von Internationalisierung verfällt. Also gerade war ja in der Zeit diese sehr schöne Diskussion, die Elisabeth von Taten angeregt hat, mit einem Beitrag über die deutschen Universitäten, wo dann verschiedene Leute zu Wort kamen und eben sagten, ich will diesen Text neu interpretieren und das geschieht nicht unbedingt, wenn ich nachweisen kann, dass ich auf zehn Tagungen in Rio und sonst wo war. Also sich tatsächlich genau zu fragen, welcher Kultur bedarf es und was schafft neues, was schafft Originalität. Und diesen Freiraum wertzuschätzen.
Und dieses Gespräch zwischen den Disziplinen und vor allem eben das, also Hierarchien machen ja immer angst. Wettbewerb macht immer angst und das blockiert eigentlich immer denken oder lenkt es in falsche bahnen. Während Kooperation und Offenheit fördert. Das ist in den deutschen Unis schon durch diese Kollegstrukturen oft mehr. Das ist schon befördert worden und da sind auch Hierarchien schon flacher geworden und ist mehr Interdisziplinarität, aber das Problem an diesen Kollegs ist natürlich, dass sie auch immer nur eine geringere Laufzeit haben und immer schon sehr früh dann auf diese Begehung gewartet wird. Dann ist klar, dann will man das nochmal. Auch da entstehen einfach sehr viele Ängste, sehr viel druck, das ist ein unheimlicher aufwand, und das führt uns alles nicht weiter. Und gleichzeitig denke ich eben, dass Bildung als Gut in der Hinsicht, dass es natürlich was anderes ist einfach als Wissen, doch das ist, was unsere Kulturen wirklich auszeichnen kann in der Welt des 21. Jahrhunderts.
Wenn man denkt, wie viele Kulturen es schon gibt in der Welt, in denen nicht so sehr das eigenständige Denken gefördert worden ist, in denen Bildung noch sehr stark verschult ist, tatsächlich als eine sehr reglementierte Wissensaneignung vermittelt wird. Dann können wir doch bauen genau auf diese Ansätze, dass die Hoffnung immer besteht, dass aus dem Querdenken eigentlich die Innovation entsteht, und das gilt es weiter zu stärken.
Ja, das ist ein super Ende für unser Gespräch.
Gerne.
Ich denke mal, dem habe ich nicht mehr viel hinzuzufügen. Ich denke grundsätzlich noch, dass es wahrscheinlich einfach auch ein wichtiger Weg ist für die gesamte europäische Gesellschaft. Gemeinschaft will ich jetzt gar nicht sagen. Sich da auch noch mehr gegenseitig zu inspirieren. Andere Länder haben da sicherlich noch mal ganz neue Aspekte mit reinzubringen. Jetzt haben wir uns mal England angeschaut. Wir werden sicherlich hier auch nochmal in andere Bereiche vorstoßen. Ich bedanke mich jetzt erst mal.
Herzlichen Dank.
Für die Einblicke hier und ich bedanke mich auch fürs Zuhören hier bei Forschergeist. Geht bald wieder weiter und ich sage tschüss und bis bald.